furniture sales have been skyrocketing
during the pandemic when there's a whole
lot of sitting around the washington
post reports
monthly sales have risen
181 percent from april 2020 to march of
this year
but a shortage of skilled workers has
contributed to unprecedented delays in
getting the furniture to customers nikki
batiste recently traveled to north
carolina america's furniture capital to
see what the industry is doing to hire
workers right now she's in our green
room nikki good morning
good morning guys i'm here in the green
room because the furniture here is
supplied by mitchell gold and bob
williams manufacturers in taylorsville
north carolina who have dedicated
themselves to inspiring the furniture
artisans of the future
here at the mitchell golden bob williams
furniture factory in north carolina
hundreds of craftsmen and crafts women
meticulously sew
trim
and staple
walking around this floor amid a
symphony of staple and nail guns you see
so much of the work is done by hand
these are called leather pullers
i grabbed this scene
watch
seen coming out
got to crank down on them hands like
robert schuford's an upholstery trimmer
are invaluable
are your hands tired though
it gets some time to get done you gotta
get used to it you get toughed up what's
the one word you would use to describe
the furniture industry right now
i would say it's
booming you started right after the 2008
crash yes ma'am and we were only working
about four days a week 32 hours a week
and now we're working 60 hours a week
and we can't get enough help and have
more work than we've ever had before all
that work is forcing furniture makers to
scramble for labor when tariffs were put
in place by the trump administration
there was new pressure on manufacturers
to move production to the u.s
today by some estimates roughly half of
upholstered furniture is made in america
when the pandemic hit people spent more
time at home and furniture sales
skyrocketed there weren't enough skilled
laborers to meet the demand
how many hands touch
one chair or couch before it ends up in
someone's house roughly it's 50 sets of
hands touch each one that's why the
company started teaching advanced trade
skills like sewing and upholstery
in-house joel de hart is vice president
of manufacturing at mitchell gold and
bob williams
we just graduated five people from that
about three months ago and now we're
starting a new class how understaffed
are you ideally we'd like 20 percent
more people working here allison
o'connor president and ceo of mitchell
gold and bob williams says the company
needs to boost both training and
interest in the craft to help fill empty
work stations we at times i think have
lost sight of the importance of
really respecting and promoting
trade skills
and so for us that's why we started our
own trading programs that's why we're
working with our obviously our local
colleges a few years ago the company
teamed up with several major retailers
to launch a nearby furniture academy
with this you know diploma you can
pretty much get a job anywhere and
you're set people are knocking on your
door yes
single mom of two young boys maria
gonzalez just graduated
the 28 year old recently completed a
six-month upholstery program now as a
skilled crafts woman she says her salary
is nearly double what she earned as a
furniture inspector
i don't have to be paycheck to paycheck
anymore
or scratching the last penny that i have
like i can actually
go out with my kids comfortably
another student we met emmanuel bose
told us he accepted a job with craft
master furniture before he even finished
his course he's recruiting me i feel
special yeah
had you ever heard of a furniture
academy
i knew they had school like i'd always
ask people man how did you get an
upholstery i want to do that and they'd
be like you got to go to school and i
was like man
a lot more goes into making a piece of
furniture than any of us ever thought
they are artisans i mean it's a craft
and it's a work we've got some of the
best in the business right here today
and there's the potential to have a nice
living oh yes
upholstery sowing cutting it's all of
them pay very well furniture industry
pays very well and it's a great option
for those kids for those people that's
wanting to learn to trade and go right
to work
i love it most of the artisans i spoke
with told me their parents or their
grandparents had also been in the
industry so very generational and by the
way but just look at the chairs that you
know it is artistry
north carolina is gorgeous too it's a
great place to live she had that beach
bum shirt they had a great coastline no
doubt and it is beautiful it's a
validation that we need to be teaching
trades in school right so vital so vital